hey I was going bros my name is yes yes
I know yes I know my forehead is huge
apparently I found this out ever since I
got a haircut you brothers have been
telling me non-stop so I just thought
I'll get rid of all the comments by
reading some right now all right
holy [ __ ] that forehead is so huge you
can land an airplane on it my 12 feet
black penis will not even be close to
covered they say you can see the Chinese
wall from space but it's actually pretty
Pie's forehead no your you know what
[ __ ] you I'm sensitive about it I have
had long hair for as long as I can
remember so for me to all the sudden
have this it's so weird
and it's not really [ __ ] helping
either way I have some important news
for you brothers I am going away forever
it gives like no ports please don't go I
love you I'm gonna miss you a Garriga
miss you so much
basically I'm going away for a month I
told heroes about this I warned you but
don't worry they're still gonna be
bitten they're still gonna be videos
coming up I've been preparing for this
trip for so goddamn long and I know it
might be weird to watch videos that
you'd be like Oh his hair is short and
then I'll have long hair and then I'll
have short hair it will teleport back
and forth
alright I've said no to so many
opportunities throughout me doing
YouTube because making videos is my
focus you bros always comes first but
I'm going away to record a TV show and I
think it's it's a really fun opportunity
that I just I really really want to do
so I hope you both understand I will do
some vlogging while I'm gone I might
even do daily vlogging if you bros want
me to I think that might be a fun thing
and turned this month into an event what
should we call it leave a comment let me
know too much with the tongue I get it
he's like a fish doesn't look like a
fish right now
a friend of ours is taking care of the
pugs while we're away I'm gonna miss it
there's so much okay I'm really nervous
but I hope it's gonna be okay so I just
wanted to let you both know so your
updated on what's going on that's all
for me for now I'll see you and I'll
still see you nothing is changing either
way I just want to say thank you both
for understanding I know not many fans
would alright and you're special that's
what I'm trying to say just you might as
well just put your butt on the screen
cuz here comes the fist just brofist